[Music]
we have some big fun things planned and
he'll be playing every night and it's
gonna be great I mean I'm always happy
when he's around ready
[Music]
Harry Styles wrapped up his week-long
residency on The Late Late Show by
indulging in a little carpool karaoke
with host James Corden the duo belted
Harry's ballad sign of the times mainly
crime performing it sometimes does it
yeah I find it quite emotional they also
sang Harry's go-to karaoke song endless
love by Lionel Richie and Diana Ross the
guys had some fun with fashion this is
an embarrassment see how do you feel
enough it's quite comfortable but I mean
it works
it's a bit nipply yours is McCoy my
actual nipple swing and even paid
tribute to Harry's favorite movie genre
rom-coms I'm just a girl standing in
front of a boy asking him to love her et
was with Corden last week the comedian
couldn't help but gush over his close
pal Harry Harry was at my wedding and
and I loved him dearly
I loved him absolutely dearly and I'm so
proud of everything he's doing in his
life
you